non so ragazzi se avete presenti file
leggimi che ci sono nelle cartelle dei
programmi dei videogiochi che scaricate
nel cibo che andrò a fare oggi c'è il
file leggimi che dice avvertenze se
giochi a questo gioco lo fai a tuo
rischio e pericolo meraviglioso cazzo
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
su tre dolls con videogame che fa che fa
male al cuore c'è tanta voglia di
giocare tanta voglia di divertirsi
quindi cominciamo parquet a [ __ ] la
tappa si muove dove mimmo io l'ho capita
però alcuna voglia di spiegarmi come si
toglie sto schifo non lo so me l'ha
terroso monti per sempre ragazzo mi son
condannato eccolo qui l'hotel resort 5
stelle ho prenotato qui siamo alle
hawaii credo ragazzi giustamente mi
sembrava un hotel buono ha detto un po
rustico ma non pensavo così tanto vorrei
capire un attimo dove cazzo se ci sono
corridori tutti uguali meraviglia che la
porta a ok l'hotel fremaux fantastico
allora sentite giorno chicca è lei piace
un tizio bellissima donna che bello che
a sentire non nomina non aspettino ma
vicini nostro schifo [ __ ] bella la
mappa che trapassa gli oggetti che io
quanto le cose bellissime che mai caso
salve siamo un giorno saviola ma ci
avrei scommesso che ti muovevi cazzo fai
spotti e io vado ragazzi è stato bene ho
valigia [ __ ] che cosa si è mosso e
stato un piacere amico io sentite una
cosa nostra
ho premuto ho premuto non ce l'ho fatta
aspettare questa è pesante cosa è
successo ma quello ragazzi ha voglia di
spiegarmi dove siamo qualcosa del genere
perché non sto pagando
ma sono io perfetto sono io che anzi mo
fantastico buongiorno ragazze ragazzi e
ragazzi merda
una ragazza era troppo non ero preparato
scusatemi quindi lo rifaccio c'era una
donna bella che mi stava aspettando
credo quindi
ragazzi ma che cazzo ha detto lancio
addosso che lancio da sfondo perfetto di
vedere fermi e non c'è nessuno che non
nega e stato orribile
cioè perché certa gente brutto visto
pure io io avevo prenotato see you see
all intervento di tufolo degli ornamenti
che si apre inventario no e basta
e basta ragazzo internati avere soffiate
apri apri apri e palacio veramente non
ho mai lanciato nel nostro stile
perché poi sembra che oggi lo faccio
apposta parlare così mai più è venuto
spontaneo ragazza è brutto sto gioco
mamma brutto forte non è che mamma sei
tuo che io mi allontano grazie mi dicono
che è [ __ ] con ragazzi però non è
tutta l'area possa andare avanti così
era questa volta che prima lo ricordo
non apro
non so dove sono ma non mi piace socio
gazich e della polvere verde a terra
brucia ancora sua musica prodotta quindi
non sono al sicuro il treno ma c'era una
fine sto gioco credo andrà ma dove cazzo
spunti tu che cazzo ci facciamo tutti
giochino con servizio bobby non l'ho
capita sta cosa ti zio mi fa piacere che
mi accompagni anche in questa avventura
meravigliosa però non è gente è proprio
il momento lista sono attaccati al muro
mi sa perché non ci sono più rumori di
fondo che non ci sono romani mikado
addosso lega quindi evitiamo di non
mettere rumori piuttosto mettete la
musica thriller ma mettete qualcosa non
quella ok non a poco si sta roba verde a
terra io ancora non ho capito me lo
spiegate voi regata che non si capisce
nel dubbio io vado avanti ancora non
però non mi piace la cosa mi fa più
paura e la tizia perché è girata e
quando la guardia si gira pian piano
bellissimo una bellissima una sega
ancora zio bocca che se tu ti sei
staccato si è staccato per mettere la
prossima volta e ti incontro non ce
l'hai più le manette vero cosa è stato
su more bruttissimi penso sia all'horror
più pesante però culo se riff che
abbiamo provato fino adesso credo c'è
niente la società non lo più ritrovata
comunque modo hanno fatto sono pieno
d'olio che non so dove l'uscita da che
voglio posso fincher le patatine
ecco la mia amica perfetta ci ha messo
poi ritrovarla sì allora senti ascolta
io prendo qualcosa che c'è sul tavolo
no no no no io potevo prendo devo
prendere lo devo prendere non tassate a
farmi con la faccia perché ti prendo a
schiaffi e devo prendere questo coso me
lo fai prendere come cazzo si prende
rega
l'ho preso ho preso il suo ne vado è
stato un piacere quella stretta di mano
poi anche un po dal dentista quando ti
capita però usciamo di
no no no no no non mi girano vicino a
milano miglior giro manco per il cazzo è
scoraggiato ma che cazzo ci fai qua
senti allora dobbiamo chiarirci noi
abbiamo chiarito via dalle palle
fantastico presso una pergamena ma non
ho capito cosa mi serve altro olio ma
basta ragazzi ragazzi ragazze ragazzi
che sono tutti i miei amici lega tutti
felici teniamoci per mano zio cerchia
tutto è successo zio di un cazzo in
sostanza fantasia da dove chiazze
spuntata ma sondata tipo a gambe
talmente veloce che non mi ha neanche
seguito proprio show ha perso le
speranze mista a sto giro c'era qualcuno
che scalciava qua dentro prima e non è
che aveva per lei molto volentieri però
non fa niente
no no no no no io lega non c entri
seport avete pazienza però scacciato
prima sei stato tu che cazzo è l'unico
che poteva schiacciare la lui non è
possibile
c'è però devi essere veloce
qualcuno allora parliamone parliamone
parliamone non ne parliamo
non ne parliamo da la messa al culto è
sentito un orgasmo a caso davvero già
perché questa non l'avevo visto prima
però chi sta messo quaden trattato se
talmente magro che potresti riuscirci
nostra roba è però va bene poi devo
trovare l'uscita solo che leggermente un
casino non ve ne siete accorti spera
salve io chiudo io chiudo mai male
basta le porte si cacci che le passano e
da merda merda pubblico un po che non si
può fare due passi legate ad fila in
grande
grande un cazzo aprile è già aperto e
aperto già aperto già pericolosa come
l'amico ceco ceo fammi entrare
sì o farmi entrare sono andato sventato
sei tu non sei il vento
no no no no no no no no no
il successo ma [ __ ] ok poi sempre
con l'ultima zona quasi da una russia si
è spento ragazzi ho vinto non fate
domande stato traumatico ma torna
traumatico forte e ragazzi da chiodo
ragazzi stato alquanto disastroso che
credetemi che ogni volta che mi tolgo ma
[ __ ] sentirò cosa non c'è non tc
mettere pure tu che c'è una giornata di
merda che lo porta a roma grazie è stato
traumatico ogni [ __ ] volta che gioco
a ste cose pazze c'era ovviamente questo
era assurdo rispetto agli altri che sta
veramente assurdo io comunque l'ho
sempre detto le ragazze sono più belle
quando sono naturali senza trucco troppo
che trovo questo è troppo
comunque queste sono pareri miei non
importa ragazzi io spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto come se i ragazzi servito è
piaciuto al suo commento mi piace anche
a parte di facebook e co meno di video
trovate la descrizione non se ne avresti
discreti noi ci rimettiamo nel prossimo
vita della ragazza